>> IT’S GREAT TO BE BACK.
THANKS SO MUCH.
GOD BLESS AMERICA.
>> Sean: GOD BLESS AMERICA.
OVER THE WEEKEND, HISTORIC
SPEECHES, THE PRESIDENT DID
CHAMPION WHAT IS RIGHTLY CALLED
AMERICAN EXCEPTIONALISM AND
AMERICAN GREATNESS.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK.
>> ON THIS WONDERFUL DAY, WE
CELEBRATE OUR HISTORY, OUR
HEROES, OUR HERITAGE, OUR GREAT
AMERICAN FLAG, AND OUR FREEDOM.
THE AMERICAN REPUBLIC STANDS
TODAY IS THE GREATEST, MOST
EXCEPTIONAL, AND MOST VIRTUOUS
NATION IN THE HISTORY OF THE
WORLD.
WE ARE THE DESCENDANTS OF THE
MOST DARING AND COURAGEOUS
PEOPLE EVER TO WALK ON THE FACE
OF THE EARTH.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, THE
PRESIDENT ANNOUNCED NATIONAL
GARDEN OF HEROES WITH AMERICANS
FROM EVERY RACE AND EVERY BACK
BACK ON, ALL-AMERICAN CELEBRATED
FOR THEIR GREATNESS IN THEIR
EXCEPTIONALISM WHICH I THINK IS
A GREAT IDEA.
THE EVER FRAIL, EVER CONFUSED,
EVER CORRUPT JOE BIDEN
CELEBRATING THE FOURTH OF JULY
IN A DIFFERENT WAY.
A HIGHLY PRODUCED, WHAT, 972ND
VIDEO OF BIDEN BASHING THE U.S.,
LIVED UP TO THE IDEA THAT ALL
ARE CREATED EQUAL.
HE NOW WANTS TO TRANSFORM OUR
COUNTRY, HE SAID, PERHAPS BIDEN
DOESN’T COMPREHEND ANY OF THIS.
BECAUSE NO COUNTRY, NO PEOPLE
ARE PERFECT, THAT’S JUST A FACT.
IT’S A BASIC FUNDAMENTAL TRUTH.
AN UNDENIABLE TRUTH.
THANKS TO THE WISDOM ARE FOR OUR
FRAMERS AND FATHERS, THEY
DEVELOP THIS GREAT
CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC, A
SYSTEM THAT ALLOWS THIS COUNTRY
THE RIGHT TO CORRECT WRONGS AND
CORRECT INJUSTICES AND ALWAYS
STRIVE AND MOVE TOWARDS
IMPROVEMENT SO WE CAN BECOME
THAT MORE PERFECT UNION.
BY THE WAY, AS THE PRESIDENT
SAID, BOTH IN HIS FRIDAY NIGHT
AND SATURDAY NIGHT ADDRESSES,
THIS IS THE BEAUTY OF AMERICA.
THAT’S WHAT WE CELEBRATE.
OF COURSE, NO, WE ARE NOT
PERFECT BUT WE HAVE THE ABILITY,
WE HAVE THE WILLPOWER TO BECOME
THAT MORE PERFECT UNION.
WE’VE MADE MAJOR, MAJOR
PROGRESS.
WE NEED TO MAKE MUCH MORE MAJOR
PROGRESS TO FULFILL THAT DREAM
OF A MORE PERFECT UNION.
FOR EXAMPLE, YOU CAN LOOK AT
THOSE GOING BACK IN HISTORY, THE
1700s, DOZENS AND DOZENS OF
OUR FRAMERS AND OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL CONVENTION,
UNSUCCESSFULLY AGAINST THE EVIL
PRACTICE OF SLAVERY.
DR. BENJAMIN FRANKLIN CALLING IT
A "ATROCIOUS DEBASEMENT OF HUMAN
NATURE."
HE IS 1000% CORRECT.
JAMES MATTIS AND CALLING IT
DISHONORABLE TO THE NATIONAL
CHARACTER.
HE WAS RIGHT.
ORDINATION CALLING SLAVE OWNERS
PETTY TYRANTS.
ULTIMATELY HUNTERS OF THOUSANDS
OF AMERICANS FOUGHT AND DIED
OVER THIS VERY ISSUE.
THAT’S OUR HISTORY.
EMANCIPATION PROCLAMATION IS
ALSO OUR HISTORY.
LATER THE VOTING RIGHTS ACT,
CIVIL RIGHTS ACT.
IT INSURED THROUGH FEDERAL LAW
AND CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS.
DO WE HAVE FURTHER TO GO?
ABSOLUTELY AND BY THE WAY, WHAT
DID BIDEN AND OTHER DEMOCRATS,
WHAT THEY WANT YOU TO FORGET IS
MANY OF THOSE THAT THEY SO
ADMIRE AND CALL THEIR MENTORS,
WELL, THEY FOUGHT TOOTH AND NAIL
AGAINST THESE IMPORTANT REFORMS.
FOR EXAMPLE, IT WAS A DEMOCRAT
GEORGE WALLACE WHO STOOD IN THE
DOORWAY OF THAT BIRMINGHAM
SCHOOL TO PHYSICALLY BLOCK
RACIAL INTEGRATION.
IT WAS A DEMOCRAT, BULL CONNOR,
WHO USED FIRE HOSES AND POLICE
DOGS TO ATTACK CIVIL RIGHTS
PEACEFUL PROTESTERS.
IT WAS OVER 100 DEMOCRATIC
LAWMAKERS WHO VOTED AGAINST THE
64 CIVIL RIGHTS BILL.
AL GORE’S FATHER, PROMINENT
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR, WELL, HE
ACTUALLY FILIBUSTER THE BILL.
SO DID ROBERT KKK BYRD, THE
FORMER KLANSMAN.
SO DID NOTED SEGREGATIONIST JAY
WILLIAM FULBRIGHT, ALL
DEMOCRATS.
KEEP IN MIND, BILL CLINTON
CALLED FULBRIGHT HIS MENTOR.
HE EULOGIZED FULBRIGHT WHILE HE
WAS SERVING AS PRESIDENT.
DESPITE HIS PAST AS A CLAN
LEADER, AND ACTUALLY THE HEAD
OF THE CLAN, MODERN DEMOCRATS
PRACTICALLY LINED UP TO
SHOWER ROBERT BYRD WITH PRAISE,
THEY EVEN MADE IN THE SENATE
MAJORITY LEADER.
HILLARY CLINTON CALLING ROBERT
BYRD THE HEART AND SOUL OF THE
U.S. SENATE.
CHUCK SCHUMER CALLING BIRD ONE
OF THE GREATEST MEN IN HISTORY.
PELOSI CALLING BYRD AN AMERICAN
PATRIOT.
BIDEN CALLING BYRD THE DEAN OF
THE U.S. SENATE, A CLOSE FRIEND,
AND A MENTOR OF MINE.
IMAGINE A DONALD TRUMP SAID THIS
ABOUT A FORMER -- ABOUT A
KLANSMAN?
KEEP IN MIND, BIDEN WANTS WORK
SIDE-BY-SIDE WITH
SEGREGATIONISTS.
THIS IS JOE BIDEN’S RECORD.
IN A SPEECH IN 1973, THEN
SENATOR BIDEN PRAISING SOUTHERN
DEMOCRATS AND SAID THAT THE
TWO-PARTY SYSTEM IN THE SOUTH
WAS "GOOD FOR THE [BLEEP]."
AROUND THE SAME TIME, BIDEN WAS
ACTUALLY WORKING WITH D
SEGREGATIONISTS.
HE WAS SLOWING AND TRYING TO
STOP INTEGRATION.
OPPOSING SCHOOL BUSING.
ACCORDING TO NBC NEWS "HE LED
THE CHARGE ON AN ISSUE THAT KEPT
BLACK STUDENTS AWAY FROM THE
CLASSROOMS FROM WHITE STUDENTS.
THAT’S JOE BIDEN.
THAT’S THE DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE.
THAT’S HIS HISTORY.
THOSE ARE QUESTIONS THE MOB HAVE
NOT ASKED HIM.
IN 1977, BIDEN WORRIED THAT HIS
CHILDREN WOULD GROW UP "IN A
RACIAL JUNGLE" AND IF
INTEGRATION IS NOT DONE IN HIS
ORDERLY WAY, WHATEVER THAT
MEANS.
1993 REFERRING TO INNER-CITY
YOUTH AS "PREDATORS ON OUR
STREETS."
AS HE COAUTHORED AN AGGRESSIVE
CRIME BILL RAMPING UP PRISON
SENTENCES FOR DOZENS OF CRIMES.
OF COURSE BIDEN’S RACIST
RHETORIC DIDN’T STOP HIM IN THE
’90s.
REMEMBER IN 2006 HE TOLD A CROWD
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A SLIGHT INDIAN
ACCENT TO WORK AT A 7-ELEVEN OR
DUNKIN’ DONUTS AND I’M NOT
JOKING.
ALSO IN 2006, BREAKING HIS STATE
WAS A STATE.
WHO WOULD BRING ABOUT THAT?
IN 2007, CALLED BARACK OBAMA,
EVENTUALLY BECAME
VICE PRESIDENT, "THE FIRST
MAINSTREAM AFRICAN-AMERICAN WHO
IS ACTUALLY ARTICULATE AND
BRIGHT AND CLEAN."
WHILE MAX, THAT IS STORYBOOK,
MAN.
WHAT?
AND LAST YEAR HE SAID "POOR KIDS
CAN BE JUST AS BRIGHT AS WHITE
KIDS."
A FEW WEEKS AGO HE TOLD THE
RADIO HOST CHARLAMAGNE THA GOD
THAT "YOU AIN’T BLACK" AND LESS
YOU SUPPORT HIM OVER TRUMP.
EXCUSE ME.
THIS IS THE GUYS THAT SAYS HE
WANTS TO TRANSFORM AMERICA.
WHAT, INTO THAT?
AFTER DECADES OF ALL OF HIS B.S.
AND 125 YEARS OF COMBINED
FAILURE OF BIDEN PELOSI AND
SCHUMER, THAT’S WOULD BE IN
CHARGE OF GOD FOR DID YOU ELECT
HIM AND HIM 120 DAYS.
TRUMP HAS DONE MORE THAN 3.5
YEARS AS I MENTIONED THAT THEY
COULD EVEN EVER THINK OF.
TRUTH MATTERS, HYPOCRISY
MATTERS.
FOR ALL OF YOU INTELLECTUALLY
LAZY PEOPLE IN THE MOB WHO WON’T
ASK THESE QUESTIONS, WANT TO
INFORM YOUR VIEWERS OF THIS
HISTORY, YOU ARE FAILING AND
DERELICT IN YOUR DUTY.
ACTIONS MATTER, DECADE AFTER
DECADE AFTER DECADE.
FIVE DECADES, BIDEN.
HE HAD AMPLE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
AMERICA A MORE PERFECT UNION.
INSTEAD, HE MADE ONE WEIRD
RACIAL STATEMENT AFTER ANOTHER.
YOU KNOW, ONE COMMENT ABOUT
INTEGRATION, SEGREGATION AND BY
THE WAY DID NOTHING TO END
VIOLENCE IN AMERICAN CITIES.
AND BY THE WAY IMAGINATIVE
DONALD TRUMP HAD SAID ANY OF
THESE THINGS OR SUPPORTED ANY OF
THESE PEOPLE, THAT THESE MODERN
DEMOCRATS SUPPORTED?
GUESS WHAT.
HISTORY MATTERS.